Bu Excel dosyasının içine bilerek 7
tuzak koydum. Aynı dosyayı Cloud'a,
Copilot'a ve chat GPT'ye vereceğim.
Hangisi gerçek hataları bulacak? Hangisi
uzun konuşup puan kaybedecek? Kazananı
videonun sonunda göstereceğim. Bu testin
sonunda yalnızca kazananı
öğrenmeyeceksiniz.
Açıklamadaki dosyayı indirip kendi
kullandığınız yapay zekayı aynı sınava
siz de sokabileceksiniz. Üstelik size
hataları buldururken verinizi bozmasını
engelleyen tek parça prompt da
vereceğim. Çünkü asıl tehlike yapay
zekanın hata yapması değil. Doğru
görünen doğru görünen yanlış bir Excel
üretmesi. Bir formül yok hatası verirse
fark edersiniz ama toplam ciro %8 şişmiş
ve grafik hala çok güzel görünüyorsa o
rapor yönetici toplantısına kadar gider.
Öncelikle cloud'u açıyorum ve hatalı
veri setimi yani kirli veri seti
dediğimiz veri setini cloud'a yüklüyorum
ve şu promptu yazıyorum. Bu dosyada
verileri kalitesini bozacak tüm
sorunları bul. Hiçbir hücreyi
değiştirmeden önce kategori, hücre
adresi, mevcut değer, neden sorun ve
önerilen düzeltme olarak listele, emin
olmadığın değeri değiştirme, insan onayı
gereklediğe işaretle özellikle şu 7
alanı kontrol et dedim ve gönderdim.
Bakalım bize bu temizleme işlemini doğru
bir şekilde yapabilecek mi? Burada
biliyorsunuz cloud, copilot ve chat
GPT'yi karşılaştıracağız.
Bakın tamamladı. Beraber inceleyelim.
243 satırlık tabloda 15 sorun buldum
diyor. Hiçbiri düzeltilmedi. En kritik
üçü tam yenilenen kayıt iki satırda
metin olarak girilmiş diyor. Hepsini
burada bana tek tek listeledi. Mesela
boş satırları verdi. İşte bunları silmek
için ya da doldurmak için benden ona
istiyor. İşte yanlış veri tipi diyor. 5
adet yazmış. Yanlış veri tipi TL olacak
şekilde yazmamış. Farklı bir şekilde
yazmış. Hepsinin sonunda normal TL
amblemi varken onda TL yazıyor. Tarih
formatı hatalı. hatalı tarih
formatlarını buldu. Yani kirli verimi
aslında olması gerektiği gibi temizledi
ve yap diyorum. Şimdi onay veriyorum
dedim
ve benim o dosyamı hazırlayacak ve bana
verecek. İndirip sonrasında tertemiz
veriyi kullanabileceğim. Şimdi chat
GPT'yi açtım ve buna yine benim o
dosyamı yüklüyorum.
Geliyorum.
Kirli veriyi ekledim ve yine aynı
promptumu yazıyorum ve gönderiyorum.
Bakalım chat GPT bana nasıl sonuç
verecek.
Chat GPT'yi de tamamladı. Bakın bu da e
243 kayıt ve 14 alan tarandı. 15 ayrı
veri kalitesi sorunu grubu belirlendi
diyor. Eee gördüğünüz gibi benzer
şeyleri buldu. Satış kimliği belirsiz
diyor. Tarih veri türü hatalı diyor.
Bölge şehir tutarsızlığı var diyor.
Fiyat türü ve değer tutarsızlığı var
diyor. Aynılarını buldu. Fakat birazcık
daha cloud'a göre yavaş hareket etti.
Chat GPT çok daha yavaş sonuçlar verdi.
Buna da onaylıyorum dediğimde otomatik
olarak bu işlemi gerçekleştirecek. Şimdi
geçelim copilot'a bakalım. Copilot neler
yapacak? Biliyorsunuz ki copilot
Excel'in direkt olarak içinde çalışıyor.
Geldim copilot'u açtım ve aynı promptumu
şimdi copilot'a yapıştıracağım.
Gördüğünüz gibi aynı promptü yapıştırdım
ve gönderiyorum. Bakalım nasıl bir sonuç
verecek, nasıl bir temizlik yapacak.
neler yapacak? Evet, copilot da bitirdi.
Bakın burada gördüğünüz gibi sonucu
verdi. 14 sütun tarandı dedi. Hiçbir
hücre değiştirilmedi dedi. Diğerleri 15
bulmuştu. Bu 14 buldu. Bakın bulduğu
kritik sorunlar burada yer alıyor. Şöyle
sağa doğru kaydırdığımızda neler
olduğunu, benzer şeyleri buldu.
Gördüğünüz gibi boş satırlar, yine tarih
formatları, yine TL vesaire hataların
hepsini buldu. Tam mükerrer kayıtlar
diyor. Mükerrer kayıtları istersem
onları da silecek. birebir aynı olan
kayıtları buldu. Onları da silebiliyor.
Neler yaptığını gösteriyor. Bakın her
şeyi verdi. Buna da onay verdiğim zaman
hataları düzeltecek. Bence üçü de
birbirine yakın çalıştı ve eee hız
olarak ise en hızlısı cloudu, sonra
copilottu, sonra da chat GPT'ydi. Siz
olsanız hangisini tercih edersiniz?
Yorumlara yazmanızı rica ediyorum. Üç
kuralı unutmayın. Bir, önce teşhis
raporu isteyin. Düzeltmeyi ayrı adımda
yaptırın. 2. Her bulguda hücre adresi ve
gerekçe isteyin. 3. Toplam tarih aralığı
ve mükerrer kayıt sayısını kendiniz
çapraz kontrol edin. Yapay zeka
hızlandırır. Sorumluluğu asla devralmaz.
Açıklamadaki Excel dosyasında kirli
veri, temiz cevap anahtarı, kullandığım
promtlar ve boş score kart var. İndirin.
Kullandığınız aracı sınayın ve kaç puan
aldığını yoruma yalnızca araç adı ve
skor olarak yazın. Böylece yorumlarda
gerçek bir karşılaştırma tablosu
oluşacak. Bu dosyayı en çok hangi araç
doğru temizler görmek istiyorsanız
kanala abone olun. Bir sonraki videoda
kazanan araca düzeltmeleri yaptırıp
temiz dosyadan sıfır formülle yönetici
dashboardu çıkartacağım. Veriyi güce
dönüştürün. Görüşmek üzere. Beni takip
etmeyi unutmayın. Yeah.